pregosian announced immediately that his
Personnel would refuse to do so we along
No Doubt with many members of this house
had been following closely the open
escalation of rhetoric from pagosia last
Friday pagosian denounced Russia's
military leadership accusing them of
bringing evil on the country and
invading Ukraine for their own personal
benefit he drove a coach and horses
through President Putin's case for war
saying and I quote the war was needed
for shoigu to receive a hero star the
oligarch clan that rules Russia needed a
war he then went on to add And I stress
I quote him directly here the mentally
ill scumbags decided it's okay we'll
throw in a few thousand more Russian men
as cannon fodder they'll die under
artillery fire but we'll get what we
want
in the early hours of Saturday Wagner
forces entered the city of rostov Von
Dawn in southern Russia and brigosian
announced that he would march on Moscow
this finally drew a response from Putin
who accused pagosian of an armed
rebellion and promised tough action and
Punishment Wagner troops promptly
Advanced more than 500 Miles northwards
towards Moscow before pregosian a
property called office operation and
announced that Wagner would return to
their bases
having condemned him as a traitor in the
morning Putin pardon progosian in the
afternoon when a Kremlin spokesman
announced that no charges would be
brought Mr Speaker the government of
course considers this an internal
Russian Affair and of course the
leadership of Russia is a matter
exclusively for the Russian people but
everybody should note that one of
Putin's Protege had publicly destroyed
his case for the war in Ukraine pagosian
said on Friday
there was nothing out of the ordinary
before the before the 24th of February
2022 the situation was Frozen with
exchanges of military action and vicious
looting by the Russians
he also said that Russia's defense
Ministry is trying to deceive both the
president and the nation that there was
incredible aggression from the Ukrainian
side with NATO support ready to attack
Russia
the Russian government's lies have been
exposed by one of President Putin's own
henchmen now the full story of this
weekend's weekend's events and the
long-term effects will take some time to
become clear and it is not helpful to
speculate propagation's Rebellion is an
unprecedented challenge to President
Putin's Authority and it is clear that
cracks are emerging in the Russian
support for the War I of course hold no
candle propagation ori's forces they
have committed atrocities in Ukraine and
elsewhere but here said out loud what we
have believed since the start of
Russia's full-scale Invasion that this
invasion was both unjustified and
unprovoked the events of this weekend
are unprecedented challenge to Putin's
Authority with an armored column
approaching his own capital city as the
situation unfolded the government
monitored and responded to developments
carefully I was briefed on Friday
evening and again regularly throughout
the weekend and by my officials on
Saturday I chaired a cobra meeting on
the situation we also have been in close
contact with our allies on Saturday I
spoke with secretary blinken and my
other G7 colleagues and I've also been
in touch with other Regional Partners my
right honorable friend the Prime
Minister spoke with President Biden
president macron and Chancellor Schultz
on Saturday afternoon Mr Speaker
despite these internal developments in
Russia Putin's bloody war in Ukraine
continues the ukrainians fight for their
survival and our Ukrainian friends are
mounting a determined counter-offensive
and steadily clawing back their
territory we will not be distracted from
our work to support Ukraine self-defense
and their subsequent recovery this
weekend's events show that it is Ukraine
and its Partners not Russia that have
the Strategic patience and resolve to
Prevail at last week's Ukraine recovery
conference we sent a clear message that
not only will we stand by our Ukrainian
friends as they resist Putin's Onslaught
but we will stand with them in the
subsequent piece as well
now that Russia's leadership cannot
justify this war even to each other the
only rightful course is for Putin to
withdraw his troops and end this
Bloodshed now Mr Speaker I commend this
statement to the house is that a foreign
well Mr Speaker can I start by thanking
the foreign secretary for being in touch
over the weekend and for the government
for providing briefings on privy Council
terms To Her Majesty's official
opposition
our greatest strength in support of
Ukraine and against Putin's invasion is
our Unity
with this in mind we are reassured to
hear that the government has been
working closely with our allies and
partners around the world
could I ask if the Prime Minister and
the foreign secretary have spoken to
their counterparts in Ukraine today or
over the weekend to reiterate to Ukraine
at all sides of this house are in for
the Long Haul and that the UK will
always support them in their fight for
democracy over tyranny the events that
unfolded Sean a light on serious
problems in Russia
pregosin has been a long time and close
Ally of Putin his military company the
Wagner group started becoming involved
in eastern Ukraine in 2014. he is not
only the owner of Wagner but also has a
media Empire that has been involved in
hybrid campaigns around the world
it's staggering that per goes in
publicly challenged not only Putin's
leadership but the false narrative Putin
used to justify his full-scale invasion
challenging the lie that Ukraine or NATO
posed a threat to Russia and stating
clearly what we all know that Putin's
full-scale invasion is failing on its
own terms
it showed that the reality and costs of
the war that Putin is trying to suppress
are coming back to haunt him the
opposition agrees it's not helpful to
speculate about where this will end up
in the long term because this is a
puzzle that is constantly shifting in
size and shape but it raises many
questions about the here and now as well
as in Ukraine the Wagner group has been
responsible for atrocities in Syria and
right across the continent of Africa
this side of the house has long called
for the prescription of a terrorist
organization we may have seen the end of
the Wagner group in its first iteration
but what does the foreign secretary know
about where it leaves its future
what was prokosin offered that led him
to run back just 200 kilometers from
Moscow well Pro goes in now disappear
Into Obscurity following his
denunciation of the lies behind the
conduct of Russians aggression in
Ukraine or could this pose a new threat
to Ukraine from Belarus
and will walk the troops continue to sow
the seeds of violence and Discord around
the world as a private militia or as
part of the regular Russian military the
most important effects of this weekend's
chaos will be on the bloody conflict on
our continent
Mr Speaker as secretary blinken has said
last February Russian forces were
approaching Kiev thinking there'd be
only that be able to capture the capital
in just a few days one year and four
months on Russia has had to defend
Moscow from the internal Rebellion what
happens in Russia is a matter of course
for Russia but one thing remains
completely certain the security of our
continent depends on Ukraine winning
this War I commend the foreign secretary
for hosting the Ukraine recovery
conference in London last week following
discussions with foreign ministers is he
confident that Ukraine will get the
military economic diplomatic and
humanitarian support it needs in the
months ahead and when we're and when are
we going to get on with not just
freezing but seizing Russian State
assets as our opposition day debate
calls for tomorrow and how does the
government plan to use its diplomacy to
Galvanize support for Ukraine among a
wider Global Coalition of countries that
in include the global South many of who
have maintained a neutral stance we must
maintain the depth of support for
Ukraine
here in the UK but amongst our allies
and partners we must also grow in its
breadth so that Putin has no choice but
to withdraw his troops so that Ukraine
wins and so the Ukrainian people get the
freedom and Justice they deserve
Secretary of State uh Madam Deputy
speaker the right honorable gentleman
raises a number of very important points
and he asks questions that of course we
and our allies are asking about what
situations May evolve as a direct
repercussion of this very public attack
on Putin's Authority by one of his
Protege and closest allies I'm not
comfortable with speculating but as I'm
sure he will understand analysts within
my department and others will look at
potential scenarios and ensure that we
have mitigations in place if appropriate
and of course he makes the very
important point the Wagner group are not
only operation operating in Ukraine but
in many other parts of the world
including Syria including Africa and we
will of course look at the potential
implications for
destabilizing impact in those parts of
the world as well I thank him for the
points he's raised about the Ukraine
recovery conference
and I will put on record the fact that
um he and the leadership of his party
have made clear their enduring support
for Ukraine I know that a number of
members from the shadow front bench made
themselves available to attend the
Ukraine recovery Conference of course I
have been in contact with my
interlocutors in Ukraine predominantly
through digital means through this
conflict sorry through this these
unfolding events in Russia and we will
of course continue to do so with regard
to diplomacy in the global South uh I
think pregosian's words and as I say
hold no candle for that man or his
organization but but the mask slipped he
has made it clear that there was no
legitimacy for this Invasion there was
no genuine uh or indeed there was no
risk at all to Russia's territorial
Integrity from NATO or others he has
made it clear that this war of
aggression was driven by the egos of
President Putin and the immediate cohort
around him they wanted to recreate an
imperial Russia as they had in the past
and the lives of thousands of ukrainians
and others have been lost in pursuit of
one man's ego it is telling that when
President ramaphosa visited Kiev
President Putin and his military thought
it was appropriate to bomb that City
whilst he was there the very
I would say almost performative rudeness
that Putin displayed towards president
prosa and those African leaders prove
the LIE that Russia is in any way their
friends and they should recognize that
what is happening here is an assault on
the UN Charter which keeps those
countries safe and they should now
recognize that Vladimir Putin of
Vladimir Putin's actions should be
denounced
Liz truss
thank you madam Deputy speaker it's
clear that Putin has been significantly
weakened in Russia
we must not use this time to let up in
all support for Ukraine
so first of all we need to make sure the
Ukrainian membership of NATO is
fast-tracked at the Vilnius NATO Summit
secondly we need to make sure there is
no talk of deals or concessions or
lifting of sanctions on Russia in any
circumstances until the war criminals
are held to account and finally we and
our allies including the ukrainians
including the polls including the Baltic
states need to make sure that we have a
plan in the case of the implosion of
Russia does my right honorable friend
agree
such a stage
remind me to have to share my uh my
right honorable friend makes incredibly
important points I have I have said uh
regularly that Ukraine's transformation
on the battlefield proves how serious
they are about the reform program that
will see them ultimately become a member
of NATO and that action should mean that
however long that NATO membership would
otherwise have taken it should of course
now be uh truncated I've made that uh
point clear and I know that is a view
that's echoed by a number of NATO allies
she is absolutely right that we should
we should recognize that some of the uh
talk about cutting a deal Ukraine
sacrificing some of its Sovereign land
in the pursuit of what would only be an
artificial and perhaps even just
temporary piece is completely
inappropriate Putin will not stop until
he has been ejected from Ukraine by the
Ukrainian people and to that end we will
continue to support them as until they
have achieved that end
um and uh ultimately
we do need to make sure that the people
responsible for initiating this conflict
and facilitating this conflict
ultimately pay for the Reconstruction
that is why we brought through uh
legislation to make sure assets remain
Frozen until meaningful and significant
reparations have been made to help
Ukraine rebuild itself after this
conflict
okay Madam Deputy speaker progressions
attempted coup failed but this shows
that Putin is in a much weaker position
than he was portrayed he's had the
partners he's withdrawn to belarusa of
course the Russian troops should also
now withdraw from Ukraine but until they
do the SMP set squarely behind the words
of NATO Secretary General this morning
who said as Russia continues its assault
it is more important than ever to
continue our support for Ukraine it is
also the case that the Wagner group
should be prescribed for the crimes that
they've committed however nothing from
Russia can now be taken for granted as
we've seen fears that pagosian now in
Belarus with wagnerite forces could be
used to attack Kiev
are real so what assessment has the UK
government made of this threat and what
coordinated plans are there with allies
to bolster cave it keeps the defenses in
such a scenario now I'm pleased is that
the secretary of state has convened a
cobra it has been reported that UK
diplomats are preparing for the collapse
of Putin's government How likely does
the Secretary of State see this in the
short to medium term and will they be
better prepared for this collapsing
regime than they were in Afghanistan
finally Ukraine has this morning
reiterated its support calls for a
simplified accession to Nato at the
upcoming NATO Summit asking
International Partners to support this
move can the Secretary of State put on
the record his support for the recession
and can he detail any steps that his
government are taking to facilitate this
such a stage Deputy speaker our support
for Ukraine and their self-defense is
unwavering uh they have earned our
support and they have shown that the
equipment that we have donated and the
training that we have provided has been
put to good use and that is why I have
no doubt that ultimately they will
endure with regard to Belarus we have
made it clear since the start of this
full-scale Invasion that any action by
Belarus to get involved in this conflict
would be met with a severe repercussions
from the United Kingdom obviously the
sanctions package we have put in place
with Russia is in a large part also
transposed across to Belarus and we will
of course keep a very close watch on the
actions that they have taken with regard
to the reports when I became a foreign
secretary I insured that the foreign
Commonwealth and development office
looked at a range of future scenarios of
course including instability in Russia
we've always made the point I will
repeat it for sake of clarity the
leadership of Russia is for the Russian
people we do not speculate or attempt to
predict what we do is plan and put in
place uh contingency arrangements and so
therefore whatever the outcome of this
conflict is we shall be prepared but I
have no doubt that with our
international support and in light of
the uh visible lack of discipline on the
Russian size the ukrainians will prevail
and we will continue working side by
side with our International Partners in
supporting them until they do
select committee militia Care thank you
madam this weekend I thank my right
prior cited it what we have learned over
the weekend is How Deep The Rock sits
within the Russian military and Security
Services we have also seen that the
social contract between Putin and the
people of Russia whereby they are forced
to give up their rights in response for
security and stability is utterly broken
we have also learned the internal
security apparatus is as broken as
Putin's offensive military foreign
capabilities but there is this is not
over yet and there is too much that
frankly does not add up so can my right
angle friend please update us how many
British Nationals remain in Russia and
will he Now launch a register for
British Nationals so that we know how
many are there should we need to get
them out and secondly can my rottenber
friend please update us how the
ukrainians have capitalized on this
chaos because we hear now they may have
taken back Villages held since 2014 by
Russian troops as well as having crossed
the danipra river which would be an
enormous turning point because it would
allow them to establish that Bridgehead
to push Russia out of Southern Ukraine
such a steak I was actually speaking my
um honorable friend makes an incredibly
important Point
um there is a quote an I will paraphrase
it because I don't have the um I don't
have the precise words in front of me
but if you trade freedom for security
you end up with neither I think the
Russian people are now recognizing that
with regards to uh what may happen in
Russia in the future as I've said we of
course look at scenario planning to make
sure that we are able to respond to
whatever happens with regard to British
Nationals within Russia as she will know
um we don't force British Nationals to
register uh with the embassy and so
therefore it is not possible for us to
give an accurate figure the UK's travel
advice has now for some years made it
clear that we advise against all travel
to any part of Russia and we also make
it clear that unless you're presence in
Russia is essential then you should
consider leaving by commercial routes
the house should recognize that because
of the situation in Russia because of
the conflict the ability of the UK to
conduct an extraction operation as we
did in Sudan is would be severely
limited probably to the point of
impossibility so I reiterate our travel
advice that British Nationals should
seek to leave the country should
consider leaving the country by
commercial routes unless their presence
is absolutely essential and on her final
Point uh of course what we what we have
seen in terms of these fractures these
cracks running through the Russian
system will of course had an impact on
those Russian troops and those Vagner
nurseries at the front line who will now
be looking over their shoulders just as
much as they will be looking forward out
of their trenches we will of course
continue to support Ukraine in their
steady and methodical recapturing of the
ground that's been stolen from them by
the Russian forces
so Chris Bryant thank you madam speaker
it was always a phenomenal demonstration
of weakness by Putin that he chose to
subcontract part of his criminal
invasion of Ukraine last year to a bunch
of fascists murderers rapists and
criminals who were mercenaries in the
Wagner group and but isn't it now time
for us to press home the advantage
shouldn't we be saying to every British
business that has any presence in Russia
get out now including Unilever and
mantrac and Infosys and all the rest of
them isn't it time that we seized
Russian State assets that are presently
sitting in British Banks to give them to
the Reconstruction of Ukraine and can
the foreign secretary please explain to
me why we have still not handed over the
money that was taken from the sale of
abramovich's Chelsea to the charity that
has been set up to reconstruct Ukraine
sexual mistakes Mr Speaker The Honorable
gentleman sadly displays a lack of
knowledge about international law
governments can cannot simply seize the
assets of individuals to do so would be
in a complete violation of the Norms of
standards of international law we have
passed legislation making it very clear
that frozen assets will remain Frozen
until uh significant and appropriate
reparations are made by those
individuals and entities that have
facilitated the conflict with regard to
the uh the Chelsea
frozen assets I refer him to the answer
I gave to him when he asked his
factually incorrect question at the
Foreign Affairs Select Committee
no not
not while sitting down
Tobias Elwood thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker Russian leaders have a
reputation of eliminating or locking up
those that show public dissent so it is
a sign of Putin's weakness that the
leader of a full-scale mutiny is offered
exile
would he agreed though that it's also
expect to expect expectant of any
dictator to blame the International
Community to blame outside interference
for domestic woes but Putin can't do
that this time because he's directly
responsible for the Ragnar group that's
his creation his private Army and he's
responsible also for the Ukraine war but
would he also agreed that Putin may be
wounded Putin's days may be numbered but
he is likely to stoop low in order to
stay in power and to justify his
invasion of Ukraine
Secretary of State my right or a friend
makes a number of very important points
prior to this Invasion Vladimir Putin's
desire was to limit uh other countries
joining NATO because of his attack we've
had Direct applications from Sweden and
NATO sorry from Sweden and Finland
Finland has now joined NATO Sweden well
on the way to doing so his desire was to
prevent Ukraine further integrating with
West Western structures his invasion has
driven Ukraine to that very thing his
invasion was meant to fraction NATO
fracture the trans Atlantic Alliance it
has strengthened it he created the
Wagner group to bolster his power in
Russia and his creation has undermined
his authority everything that Vladimir
Putin has done has been
counterproductive to his own explicit
aims that is why I have no doubt that
with our continued support and the
support of the International Community
Ukraine will prevail they will win and
they will return their country to its
sovereignty
Valerie Vaz
and deaf speaker can I stop by wishing
the foreign secretary and his family
well at the NATO PA in Luxembourg we
unanimously passed a declaration with a
clause that specifically recognizes the
Wagner group as a criminal and terrorist
organization could he ensure that the
Prime Minister also supports this at the
Vilnius Summit
Secretary of State uh speaker the right
honorable lady makes an important point
about the nature of the vehicle group I
know there are variations of definitions
about how to describe them at the UK
prescribes sorry the UK sanctions of
Wagner group in its entirety and certain
key members of it as well and we will
continue to ensure that we
um
undermine the ability of that mercenary
organization to create conflict create
conflict not just in Ukraine but around
the world
speaker my instinct here is that this
Norfolk water this that meets the eye
and no doubt as Military Intelligence
the foreign intelligence let us through
which we'll know more
given however that NATO's imperative has
to be to reject Russian forces from
Ukraine and not interfere in domestic
Russian affairs can I please ask the
foreign secretary whether he feels that
this now makes a Ukraine victory in
Ukraine more or less likely
my uh honorable and Gallant friend will
know how important the moral component
is in the success of a military
operation those Russian troops those
Wagner mercenaries will now be less
confident about the logistics supply to
the front line to the Integrity of their
military leaders and the strength of
their military planning that will that
will inevitably make them less effective
as a fighting force however we should
recognize that Wars are inherently
unpredictable the ukrainians have always
had the stronger morale their
willingness to endure is legendary and
what we have seen is that Putin's
expectation that it would be the west or
the ukrainians that would run out of
resolve first has been shown to be a
fundamentally flawed hypothesis and what
we are seeing is the cracks emerging
within the Russian system rather than
the West
Stuart Malcolm McDonald
I'm very grateful Madam Deputy speaker
the global evil that is the Wagner group
has finally come home to cause problems
for the president and the Kremlin I
think the secretary is absolutely
correct to say that we shouldn't
speculate on regime change I don't think
that would be helpful so with that in
mind we should focus on what he can do
the Wagner group as has been mentioned a
number of times has been an evil in
Syria in Ukraine right across the
continent of Africa so can you outline
how he intends to along with other
Allied countries
formulate a plan to start degrading the
Wagner group's capabilities its
Logistics its finances and would he also
give consideration to the foreign office
funding the collection of evidence of
Wagner war crimes across the world for
which many universities in this country
alone would be very well pleased to help
with
remember speaker The Honorable gentleman
makes I think an important and valid
point we have worked closely with our
International Partners in terms of the
collection of evidence of war crimes in
Ukraine I think he makes a very good
point I need to look at the logistical
and practical implications of doing so
on a wider scale but of course a big
part of the Wagner groups sales pitch to
those vulnerable countries who employ
them in lieu of having a credible Armed
Force is their their idea of
vulnerability their idea of inevitable
success that has been massively
undermined by their own actions we will
continue to highlight the
inappropriateness of of arguments
activity around the world including in
Africa we will continue to impose and to
[Music]
impose those sanctions and enforce those
sanctions to undermine the evil that
organization does around the world
Vicky Ford thank you madam Deputy
speaker many commentators have pointed
out that this weekend's activity may
have wounded Putin and we know that
wounded animals can be very dangerous
with this in mind how concerned is he
about reports that Russian forces may
have placed Minds at the nuclear power
plant
are we facing the potential risk that
perhaps is part of a scorched Earth
policy we could see a major nuclear
incident
my right type of friend makes it a very
important point I had a meeting with
Rafael Grossi who's the director general
of the IE EA and we discussed the safety
of these Apparition nuclear power plant
both in terms of
being center point of a military
conflict and also in light of the damage
to the dam the low water levels in the
denipa used for cooling I can assure you
that we assess all potential credible
scenarios and look to mitigate wherever
we can
done Jarvis thank you madam Deputy
speaker it was widely reported back in
May that the UK government were actively
considering prescribing the Wagner group
as a terrorist organization accepting it
is early days can ask the foreign
secretary whether an assessment has yet
been made as to what the ramifications
would be for Putin if he sought to
amalgamate the Wagner group into the
Russian conventional Armed Forces
I I think the honorable and Gallant
gentleman for the point he's just made
we we do of course uh keep the decisions
around prescription of organizations
open it's always a cross-government
department but he will also know we do
not uh typically comment on future uh
prescriptions or designations we have of
course looked at the implication back in
June when the announcement came out that
volunteers were going to be contracted
to the Russian Ministry of Defense we
did of course look at the implications
of the sanctions structure and others on
that I'm not at Liberty to discuss the
outcome of those liberations but I can
reassure him and the house these are
things that we have had under
consideration
Savannah Jenkins thank you madam Mr
Speaker many in this house and elsewhere
are commenting about the opportunity
this provides to the Ukrainian Armed
Forces to press home their advantage
while the Russian command chain is in a
shambles but isn't it just a truism that
the more help we can deliver to the
ukrainians now the quicker we can do it
the more likely we will end this war
quickly with a favorable outcome so what
are we doing to press home the advantage
by galvanizing ourselves and our allies
to give more support to the Ukrainian
Armed Forces
is absolutely right that the the
situation over the weekend does make uh
the command control of the Russian
forces less effective I can assure him
in the house that we have never been
distracted from our primary goal which
is to support the ukrainians financially
and militarily so that they can press
home their counter-offensive and I can
assure him in the house that we will
continue to do exactly that
thank you very much remember please
speak up media reports over the weekend
suggested that President Putin decided
to flee Moscow and relocate to Saint
Petersburg when he learned of pregosin's
Wagner's Advanced towards Moscow this of
course is in stark contrast to president
zielinski who bravely remained in Kiev
when faced with a full-scale Russian
invasion so what assessment has a
foreign secretary made of these reports
and their veracity
The Honorable gentleman makes an
incredibly important point about the
personal courage that President zelenski
demonstrated at a point in time when
Russian tanks were advancing on keep
have had the pleasure to meet him on a
couple of occasions and it is a genuine
privilege to do so we do of course look
at a wide range of Open Source reporting
what I would say to uh to the house is
that much of this is speculative much of
this turns out to be inaccurate we do of
course attempt to sift as much as we can
but it's very difficult to get a clear
picture about the events on the ground
so what we tend to do uh as he will
understand is work on a range of
potential scenarios and have our
planning around the most credible most
likely those scenarios
Bob Sealy speaker the latest news if it
is to be if it is to be believed is that
8 000 Wagner mercenaries are going to be
joining you're getting pregosian in
Belarus uh in a small town called the
sipofichi where some bases I understand
are being built under lukashenko
dictator lukashenka's request without
wishing to speculate whether this
brigade size force is going to in the
short to medium term be a greater threat
to lukashenko or to Putin will he
reassure us that their movements that
this base is going to be very closely
monitored given its proximity not only
to Russian nuclear weapons and we've
seen the very dual loyalties that Putin
uh that the Russian army have towards
Wagner but also now their proximity to
Nato borders
my honorable girlfriend makes an
incredibly important point I'm not at
all sure I'd be very comfortable with 8
000 Wagner Fighters being my friends uh
anywhere or anytime soon we have made it
absolutely clear to the Belarusian
government that we expect them not to be
involved in and not to facilitate
attacks into Ukraine we will of course
keep a very very close eye on reporting
around the locations and activity of
those Wildlife fighters in Belarus
Paul Williams
speaker the United Nations the
commission of Human Rights says that
since the stance of the war up to this
may there have been 15 000 civilian
casualties
what supports is this government giving
in situ to these civilian victims of
Russia's illegal War
gentleman makes uh an incredibly
important Point what we have seen
horrifically is the specific targeting
of civilians and civilian infrastructure
by Russian forces in Putin's uh or of
aggression the UK has in addition to our
Military Support also supported the work
to rebuild Ukraine and rebuild the
particularly the energy infrastructure
that was so essential during the winter
the Ukraine recovery conference which we
hosted in the UK last week also saw the
commitment of 60 billion
including a 50 billion pound promise
from the uh European Union which was
hugely valued for Ukraine's recovery
reconstruction and the reform we will
keep working to support the rebuilding
of Civilian infrastructure I've
witnessed that on my visits to Ukraine
and that will remain part of the UK
support to the ukrainians in their
self-defense yeah
Jonathan General Deputy speaker with the
increased threat of disintegration of
the Russian Federation does my right
honorable friend agree that it will
become even more important to Monitor
and protect Russia's Future Leaders and
influencers like free Russia's Vladimir
karamirsa already twice poisoned and now
sentenced to 25 years in prison for
promoting democratic values and will he
look to extending the sanctions on his
tormentors from only five people to more
of the 38 Russian State gangsters who
have been identified so far
the work that's been done by Vladimir
caramoza and others like him who have
stood up publicly to criticize the
brutality of the Putin regime is
admirable we continue to call upon his
immediate release uh my uh right on
Defenders right of course that we have
sanctioned a number of the individuals
who have been involved with his
completely inappropriate and unjustified
detention he will know that we don't
speculate about future designations but
I am my department have heard what he
said
Sir Mark Hendrick Madam Deputy speaker
can have the foreign secretary fee and
his Department have managed to ascertain
the rationale behind pregocians moved
towards Moscow was it because Russia
forces were shell in the Wagner group in
Ukraine was he not being paid enough or
been paid at all
was he because he was critical of shoigu
and garasimov and the effectiveness of
the Russian forces actions in Ukraine
and indeed why did he stop short of
going as far as he could towards Moscow
I'm depressed speaker it's it's hard to
know with any certainty about what the
trigger event for this uh armed uh
Advance on Moscow would be over a number
of weeks we've seen increasingly
escalating rhetoric from pregosian uh he
has he has complained about his troops
being starved of supplies he's
complained about ineptitude in the
Russian military leadership he has made
all kinds of claims it's not possible
for us to assess which one of those is
the trigger point but of course we have
been watching as his comments have
become increasingly critical and
increasingly intense
think for me the main thing I take away
from this is the fact that he makes it
absolutely clear that this is a war of
aggression this is a war driven by
Vladimir Putin's ego rather than by any
threat to Russia itself whilst there's
much that we do not know and much that
we do not believe I think that I'm
willing to believe that that is very
much the case
Sir James dodridge your Madam Deputy
speaker the Wagner group has a nefarious
interest in a whole raft of African
countries Belen Sahel and across central
Africa
um I'm particularly concerned at places
like Mali that take direct instructions
from the Wagner group as if they're the
Russian government in places like Niger
where there's a French get all the
uranium from the DRC whereas all the
critical minerals in these countries
we've got small but excellent
representation can I urge to foreign
secretary to consult with them to see
what happened was happening Development
Group on the ground and to see if we can
fill that vacuum that they're going to
group leave in a more productive way
both for their economies and Ours
incredibly important uh point about the
nature of organ group's activities in
Africa I speak with African leaders uh
those who have vulgar mercenaries in
their country or near their borders I
have highlighted the fact that these are
not people that can be trusted in any
country whose defense relies upon them
as the Russians have now discovered any
countries who uh rely upon them for
their defense are inherently uh
vulnerable of course I will talk with
our representatives in Africa to look at
the impact of the Wagner group's
activities and what we can do in close
coordination with our International
friends and allies to ensure those
African countries are safe without the
need for mercenary forces
Richard Ford thank you madam Deputy
speaker I think many of us can accept
the the point that the Secretary of
State makes about how this uh is a
matter for for the Russian people it's
an internal matter in Russia but of
course it does have a bearing on
Ukraine's self-defense
the um the the ukmod estimates that 60
000 Russians have been killed in the
adventure in Ukraine uh the BBC and its
local Partners have verified or
confirmed like 25
000 and yet the Russian state is
suggesting only 6 000 have been killed I
wonder what his Department can do to try
to uh improve the awareness in Russia of
the toll that this is taking on
conscripts on soldiers and their
families
I'm Deputy speaker The Honorable and
Gallant gentleman makes an incredibly
important point that Vladimir Putin has
not only been lying to the world about
his motivations for this war of
aggression but he's been lying to the
Russian people about the implications
maintaining that lie became increasingly
difficult because of the events of this
weekend of course our primary sympathy
is with the people of Ukraine is their
country that's been brutalized they're
people that are being murdered they're
women and children being raped or uh
being stolen but it's also the case that
Russian soldiers as pregosians said in
his comments are being used as cannon
fodder by a Russian leader who does not
care for them or their families the more
Russians see this the more they will
realize that they are just as much
victims of Putin's uh ego as anyone else
in the world he is absolutely right the
leadership of Russia is exclusively for
the Russian people but I think the
Russian people will now see how very
badly they have been LED
James
Mr Speaker the Russian foreign foreign
minister lavron has announced this today
that um he is content for the Wagner
mercenary group to continue its
activities in Africa notwithstanding
pregojin's role in the attempted coup
over the weekend does my right honorable
friend agree that that statement simply
serves to underline the increasing
weakness of the Russian regime but does
he also agree that a leaderless Wagner
is potentially even more dangerous and
demands the most careful scrutiny by the
United Kingdom and its allies
makes an incredibly important point it
is not possible for us to predict I do
not intend to speculate but he's
absolutely right the events are this
weekend have made things potentially
more dangerous in all the places where
Wagner is is active and more predictable
which is why we will we must and we will
keep a very close eye on Wagner group
activities not just in Ukraine but
around the world and will seek to show
those leaders who are relying on Wagner
that they're they're their Reliance on
that mercenary group is wholly
ill-placed
direct week thank you Monday speaker uh
there's no doubt that the events of this
weekend show again why we need to ramp
up our support for Ukraine and my
question to the to the fund secretary is
this about intelligence is because we've
heard various scenarios and Views about
what what once and what consequences are
this weekend uh is he concerned that
really having trouble getting decent
intelligence what's going on in the
Russian leadership and that support
group around Putin and those those power
Brokers and really what are we doing
about that because in fact his answer to
my honorable friendly member for Preston
sort of underlined that point so I have
a concern that we really are struggling
to get any really intelligent what's
going on inside Russia
it's a long-standing convention in the
house that we did not discuss
intelligence matters the dispatch box
what is his estimate of the number of
Wagner troops deployed in the Ukrainian
theater and what's his estimate of the
proportion of those who will agree to
come under Russian military command on
the 1st of July
my honorable friend uh asks an important
uh question uh the figures are of course
now uh massively less predictable than
they uh were uh uh just 72 hours ago we
will of course keep a very close eye to
see
um which troops might transfer to the
Russian Ministry of Defense which troops
might still desire to remain independent
and Russia's reaction to them this is a
continually evolving situation we will
of course keep a close eye on it and we
will ensure however throughout this that
we remain absolutely committed to
supporting Ukraine in their
counter-offensive
Madame Deputy speaker the events of this
weekend China Spotlight on the weakness
of the Putin regime in Russia but we
knew the weakness was there anyway
because that's the whole reason for
invading in the most aggressive and
unprovoked manner to deflect attention
from the internal travails Within Russia
nevertheless though whatever this
weekend's events pregosian is not a
catalyst for peace he is not an advocate
for good governance and he is no friend
of anybody in the International
rules-based System so does the foreign
secretary agree with me that the
internet International Community must
maintain the utmost vigilance with how
this dynamic between pregosian and Putin
unwinds and Kenny advise the house that
what will that vigilance look like from
a UK perspective
remember
to speak councilman makes it incredibly
important points the pregosian the
Wagner group have been responsible not
just in Ukraine but other parts of the
world for truly appalling acts of
violence so he is absolutely right the
fact that pagosian turned into an enemy
of Putin does not suddenly make him a
friend of ours we remain absolutely
clear-eyed about the nature of that
individual nature of that organization
and I can assure him and of course I
won't go into detail but I can assure
him we will be keeping a very very close
eye on their activities not just in the
European theater but in other parts of
the world as well
Robin Miller thank you madam Deputy
speaker it is wise that we're not drawn
into speculation in this chamber about
what is happening or has happened uh in
in Russia but is equally it's important
that we're not distracted and remain
focused on supplying and support for you
Ukraine in a bloody conflict that they
are engaged in as it continues
so can he assure the house then that
that military support for Ukraine will
continue and on these practical points
the delivery of military equipment as
requested and agreed here in particular
vital air defense missiles
speaker I can assure my honorable friend
that throughout the uh high profile uh
events of this weekend in the UK and I
confirm this in my phone call with G7
foreign ministers our friends around the
world remain relentlessly focused on
providing ukrainians with what they need
where they need it when they need it to
give themselves the very best chance of
a successful counter-offensive uh this
year
Alison thulis here it was apparently
reported in the Wall Street Journal that
the U.S is considering delaying further
sanctions on the Wagner Group after this
weekend's events given all that he has
said about the danger that the Wagner
group presents uh worldwide it can he
comment uh or any further where the UK
stands and further sanctions against
them
speaker the UK has sanctioned
Development Group in its entirety and
members with it obviously it would be
inappropriate for me to comment on other
countries sanctions decision although I
would make the point that whilst we
regularly do a compare and contrast
between government sanctions our our
domestic legislations mean the nature of
our sanctions do not always match
exactly but both the US and the UK and
our friends around the world are
relentlessly focused on the evil that's
being perpetrated by this organization
we will continue to respond robustly
Simon fell thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker
um my writable friend is quite right not
to speculate on
um the implications the Russians state
after the events of the last couple of
days and to focus instead on the illegal
Invasion on of Ukraine but but on that
the rebuilding of the state is also
important one of the clearest routes to
doing so is to use the seized assets of
kleptocrats and criminals to help that
rebuilding effort with my writable
friend agree
the UK government's position has been
clear those people who funded
facilitated supported this brutal
invasion of Ukraine have got to be the
people that bear the brunt for its
rebuilding at the Ukraine recovery
conference last week a huge number of
countries represented uh almost 60
countries represented uh companies with
a combined net value uh in the excess of
five trillion
uh were um at the the organization sorry
at the event all of us were committed to
make sure we support Ukraine in its
recovery but whilst we may look to
de-risk Mars whilst we may look to pump
Prime and whilst we may look to give the
first line of support ultimately the
people responsible for this destruction
should be the people responsible for
rebuilding
okay first of all thank the foreign
and for the encouragement that he gives
this house and more importantly an
encouragement that he gives you Korean
and thank him for that
um with the um very um interesting
development in Russia over the last few
days will the foreign outline
um what steps have been taken to send
the message to Putin that wise kittens
and answers are on a shaky fitting the
land of those in support of Ukraine has
never been more solid and more strong
and does the foreign secretary believe
now is the time to increase support to
Ukraine in terms of arms and Aid to
underline not very Point thank you
oh Madam Deputy speaker we uh we we wait
for the honorable gentleman from
frankfurt's contribution uh often in
debates because he's always he's always
thoughtful and has an unerring ability
to hit the nail on the head when it
comes to the main thrust of our debate
and he is absolutely right in his
assessment that Vladimir Putin invaded
Ukraine believing Ukraine was vulnerable
and fragile that the West were
vulnerable and fragile that somehow we
were fickle and that we lacked resolve
and what we have seen in the intervening
15 or 16 months is the Ukrainian
standing firm their Alliance of friends
getting larger and stronger by the day
and the commitment that we saw at the
Ukraine recovery conference underlines
that and indeed it is Russia it is Putin
and the mercenaries that he's contracted
to do his brutality that have shown
fragility and fracture and he is
absolutely right now is the time to
enhance our support to Ukraine to give
them not just the encourage management
and the political support but the
Practical support the finances in the
military support to get the job done and
I can assure him and the house that is
exactly what we are going to do
Dakota
that concludes proceedings on the so it
always concludes proceedings when The
Honorable member for strangford asks the
last question
to concludes proceedings on the foreign
secretary's statement thank you very
much I will pause for a moment to allow
the change in personnel
and before we come
to the next statement
I am required to put on record Mr
speaker's disappointment that an
important policy has not been announced
first to this house not only have
ministers been on the airwaves training
the policy on lung cancer but a detailed
press notice appeared on the
Department's website well before the
start of this statement Mr Speaker has
repeatedly made it clear that such
announcements should be made first to
this house and that to do otherwise is
discourteous to this house and this
practice must not continue here here
Secretary of State for Health and Social
care Steve Bartley thank you madam
Deputy speaker and first may I address
those remotes on behalf of of Mr Speaker
of course any disappointment express my
uh by Mr Speaker is a matter of concern
uh no discussy was of course uh wished
on the part of the government it may be
helpful just to clarify that no change
of policy is being announced in this
statement it is an expansion of an
existing policy which I hope the house
will regard as good news but of course
we very much take on board any concerns
that Mr Speaker has expressed Madam
Deputy speaker with permission I would
like to make a statement on our national
lung cancer screening program for
England around a quarter of patients who
develop lung cancer are non-smokers and
we all remember our much missed friend
and colleague the former member for oh
Bexley and sidcup